so let's talk just a minute by way of
digression about this term alpha
in this case actually i'll hate them the
verbal form
this is a term that hegel is going to
use
and
you could translate it as sublation
which is one common translation for it
which has at least the
what seems to be a a downside but is
actually an upside and that's not a
familiar term for us
so we're less tempted to misinterpret it
you know you can also translate it as
transcending provided that you include
within the notion of transcending not
just a like leaping past or going beyond
or going to a higher level but also
bringing the previous level along with
you because this is what happens as we
move from one
shape or form of consciousness to
another and this is what happens
internal to those as as they're
undergoing their conflicts their
contradictions and then their their
developments
we've seen that for hegel
um
development doesn't take place by first
having a
and then b emerges out of it somehow and
it's contradicted to it and then b says
screw you to a and leaves it behind and
everybody says b is so much superior to
a let's forget it
instead uh a is preserved in b somehow
including their opposition including
what it was that was essential in in a
gets preserved in b and b actually turns
into c
or d or e because this can be a very
long and iterative process
that's ablation
we're going to come back to this in a
lot of other places so i don't want to
spend too much time on it right now but
i thought it was important just to
stress this
so
we're not going to get our head around
time
by thinking of it in terms of
mathematics
here i'd like to bring up a little bit
of a digression as well
why would there be this sense that we
ought to think of time in terms of
mathematics is it just that we're
attracted to math well you know this
this idea has a long pedigree
it goes all the way back to aristotle
who said that time is the
number
of
change or quantity or however you want
to
to parse it out of kinesis can i say i
was actually in the greek
um and sometimes this is talked about in
terms of motion but he's really talking
about the broader category of change
he also says a few other things about
time that i'll get to in a moment that
that tie in more closely to what hegel
is expressing here
well let's fast forward now to somebody
else who's very important in the
understanding of the relationship of
time to number and that's augustine
augustine uh
says that strictly speaking
at least from our perspective
the presence is all that there is and
it's this tiny little slice and now with
this presence go on
the past doesn't exist the future
doesn't yet exist
so where does all this stuff come from
how do we measure something that doesn't
actually exist i.e time
well we measure it because we actually
have a capacity for keeping track of it
and we do so through a kind of numbering
for example if we're talking he uses the
examples of long and short syllables
because because latin poetry actually
was not based on rhyme
end rhyme as we're used to in english it
was instead based on meter and meter
depends on long and short syllables
depends on the vowels there's a whole
long story there that i don't need to go
into suffice it to say
what augustine was pointing out is that
in our minds we actually compare
experiences against each other and we
can say this experience is twice as long
as that one
now
is it time itself that's dictating that
or is it are imposing a structure on
things
that's doing so
that's the key question there of course
with augustine there's god in the
picture and so there's the divine mind
and that that complicates things as well
fast forward now to to kant who is you
know looking at these matters
after having had you know some some
great mathematicians themselves
trying to make sense of these things
like newton like
leibniz kant will treat time
as something that is not out there
existing in itself but actually
something that is a form of our
intuition of things we we actually have
to put our experiences into time and
space as well
in order for them to to be able to make
sense to us in order for there to be
sequence and so again time and number
are intimately connected in the minds of
many of these people who are who are
treating metaphysics
so hegel is going to depart from them
and he's going to ask you know what is
time
in order to broach this question
we really need to get away from
mathematics
and
engage in metaphysics and hegelian
metaphysics is phenomenology it is
attentive to what's going on in
consciousness how do things actually
appear to us
i'm just the perceiver i'm not i don't
know the dignity of the object right and
this means that it's possible for
consciousness
to
cause its own
deception
something that we ought to think about
as an aside is whether this whole
process here this whole picture that
we've got
isn't itself a way that consciousness
sometimes deceives itself
in modern philosophy and in naive
uh grasp on perception
in any case we're going to want to if
we're good consciousnesses
don't do any of this
right just stick with this and then
we're going to be
a-okay we we grasp the truth as such we
don't want to be caught in deception if
we are
it's our own fault
we're the ones who impose that upon
ourselves like you know descartes says
for example in his meditations when i'm
deceived i i can you know say that
there's some sort of evil deceiver out
there but that evil deceiver can't
really deceive me if i actually stick to
what i know
and don't add or subtract anything he
doesn't use those words but that's
hegel's terms
you